F: Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Monsieur Gérémy Credeville
G: Eh bonjour
F: Alias G, c'est le plus beau guest que j'ai eu en 53 vidéos les mecs.
G: Merci
F: On sort du plateau des Comics dont fait partie Gérémy Credeville, c'est au Blancs Manteaux
et on en profite pour faire une vidéo parce que ça sera la vidéo de demain
je la mettrai à 17h demain
G: Ah d'accord
F: Parce que je suis en flux tendu mon pote en ce moment
*rire*
F: Et G ce soir t'as fait de l'impro, j'ai trouvé ça super cool, c'était une bonne idée
G: Merci
F: C'est à dire qu'il fait pas d'impro dans son spectacle mais ce mec là vient de l'impro en fait.
Je me suis dis on prend le thème de l'impro pour cette vidéo
J'aimerai que tu choisisses toi même dans ta tête 2 mots
Comme quand toi, tu demandes aux gens des mots, tu sais pour tes impros
Tu choisis 2 mots dans ta tête, tu ne me les dis pas
G: D'accord
F: Ok. Tu les as en tête?
G: Je les ai en tête
F: Je ne peux pas les connaitre?
G: Et non !
F: On est bien d'accord avec ça
F: Et je vais te demander de faire une impro avec ces mots là. Ok?
G: D'accord
F: Là pour l'instant je ne t'avais pas dit pourquoi tu me les donnais c'était pour pas que tu te facilites toi même la tâche.
Tu vas devoir me faire une impro avec les mots que t'as choisi
et que je ne connais pas et du coup mon but à moi, ma mission, mon job c'est de retrouver quels mots
tu places, quels mots tu t'es imposé pour ton impro
F: D'accord donc si dans ta tête tu t'as choisi soleil et nuage
Dans ton impro tu vas les dire à un moment donné et moi faut que je me dise:  Ah oui c'est Soleil et Nuage, c'est les mots de son impro
Mais pour me piéger, n'hésites pas à en mettre pleins
G: D'accord
F: Peut-être les mots classique qu'on te donne dans les impros
F: Je sais qu'on donne toujours anticonstitutionnellement
t'hésites pas à en mettre pleins pour m'embrouiller
ça marche ?
G: Ok, je vais tenter
F: C'est parti
on tente le coup. Ça filme là, ça filme là. Action
G: Oh mon dieu, je suis complètement bourré. J'appelle un Uber
Prrr hop application Uber
Oh aucune voiture n'est disponible
Roh mince comment vais je faire je ne sais pas. J'appelle Hitch. Faut peut être en citer 3 euh...
*rires*
Ou l'autre là...
F: Chauffeur privé
G: Chauffeur privé voilà bim
Ah votre chauffeur arrive dans quelques minutes. Ok, génial il arrive !
Bonjour Monsieur, vous êtes bourrés ?
Euh oui
Ah vous le faites vachement bien !
Merci beaucoup
Allez-y monter
Je monte..Je monte à l'avant ?
Non on est pas chez Hitch
Ah d'accord, je monte derrière, oh c'est génial
Vous avez une musique préférée?
Oh non mettez ce que vous voulez
*bruitage trompette* Oh du blues c'est génial
*trompettes*
Vous préférez le rock?
Ben mettez si vous voulez
*trompettes* mais vous m'avez pas demandé l'adresse?
Eh eh fallait là dire
Bon ben à ce moment là je prends un taxi
Compliqué non?
F: Là t'as finis l'impro?
G: Bah...Ah oui moi c'est des impros sans début sans chutes c'est...
F: Je je...
G: Quand tu disais que j'étais bon en impros hein !
F: Bah oui parce que... parce que moi j'ai...
G: Il vous avez bien menti !
*rires*
G: Ça dépend des mots, on va juger ça aux mots
Moi y'a un mot que je pense avoir chopper mais du coup je croyais que ça allait continuer et qu'il y avait un 2ème mot
du coups je vais les écrire ici
Je vais prendre un bloc note, je vais les écrire là
et puis comme ça il le voit ici avec la caméra
G: Le suspens moi je fais le *battement de tambours*
F: Pour moi, il y en a un c'est sur c'est celui ci, je l’écris bien ici tac
Et alors du coup, faut que j'en trouve un 2ème
G: ouais
F: Ouais je dirai ça
G: Tu es sur?
F: Je sais pas
G: Je sais pas non plus
F: Allez vous le voyez je vous le fait voir là, je vous le fais voir là rapidement
G: Salut Gary. A bientot
F: Voilà c'est super comme ça tu as pas vu
G: Tu voulais que je le vois
F: Alors, hein?
G: Tu voulais que je le vois?
F: Non surtout pas !
G: Ah nickel
Très belle diversion des 2
G: La Comics Squad
F: Tellement, j'avais tellement tous prévu
F: Ok vous l'avez bien vu, vous l'avez vu aussi sur cette caméra. Est ce que tu peux dire qu'elles sont les mots que tu as placé dans ton impro? Quels mots tu t'es imposé à placer dedans?
G: Il y avait voiture et il y avait blues
F: J'avais Blues. Le 2ème j'étais pas bien sûr de l'avoir mais je l'ai eu
G: Le sal**d
F: Blues et voiture. Blues c'était clair, voiture j'étais pas sûr
G: Joli
F: J'ai hésité sur le Uber, un truc comme ça
G: Et voilà, ben écoutes bravo
F: Bravo à toi, merci ça t'a plu ça?
G: Ah ben ça...
F: Cool
G: Je suis sur le cul
F: Eh oui, comme tu étais assis du coup ça comptais pas tellement
F: Merci mon G... Allez voir son spectacle il est vraiment mortel. Tu joues ?
G: Du mercredi au samedi aux Blancs Manteaux
Voilà les mercredis c'était à 21h et du jeudi au samedi à 19h30
C'est pour ça que c'était un peu compliqué
du mercredi au samedi aux blancs manteaux
F: Merci beaucoup ! Abonnez vous à la chaîne c'est très très important. Rendez-vous ce soir à 20h au grand point virgule
pour le plateau Hallucinations collectives et autres illusions.
Et rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog.
Ciao !